[Music]
hey everybody thanks for being here
today
I am going to do a talk on well it's a
long title using a patchy era calcite
parquet all to build a relational cache
and this is sort of our experience at
Dromio and what we did and talking about
how these different technologies work
together to solve performance problems
and get to your data more quickly so
quickly Who am I
I am the CTO and co-founder of Dromio
very active in a number of open source
communities I'm an apache member vp of
apache era which is new project that's
coming to it about for about a year and
a half I'm also a PMC of arrow calcite
the Apache Incubator as well as Herron
which is an incubating project that came
out of Twitter for streaming purposes so
quickly
a agenda I this doesn't move so I'll
stay real close here quickly agenda I'm
gonna do a quick tech background err on
each of the three technologies that I'm
talking about and then I'm gonna go into
talking about different kinds of caching
techniques and specifically relational
caching go into depth on how that works
what we do when we try to do definition
of relational caching as well as
matching relational caching and then
talk about a little about it as you need
to without with caching is updates and
how you deal with changing data and then
a few closing words and I'm gonna go
through this pretty quick but afterwards
I have office hours so if you want to
drill into a well a particular topic in
more detail than I would be happy to do
so but I'm gonna try to cover a wide
range of things to sort of get get the
idea across here so let's start out with
a tech background so what are the three
projects we're talking about so the
first is Apache Aero so Apache ro as I
mentioned is about a year and a half old
it is a project focused on in-memory
comm their processing specifically for
sort of various types of big data
purposes it has sort of two main
components to it the first is a
representation of data in memory no
matter what type of language you're
using and the second is a collection of
different algorithms and libraries to
work with this representation of data
designed to work with any programming
language and it's books focused on both
what you think of a sort of traditional
relational data which is rows and
columns data as well as sort of more
common
more modern data like complex data
nested data you know heterogeneous types
that kind of thing
arrow even though it's fairly new has
been incorporated in some of some really
interesting projects so one is is that
Candice now is incorporating arrow is
sort of its next-generation in-memory
format for processing spark also with
two three which is coming out I think
shortly is also in has incorporated
arrow as an internal representation for
certain types of processing and then
join me other product that I worked on
most recently also uses arrow and
internally the second piece of sort of
ingredient that we're talking about here
is apache calcite cal so it's been
around for about five or six years as an
Apache project that code has actually
been in development for I think over 15
years total so a huge amount of
capability here you can think of it as
kind of like a database in a box without
storage but it's actually designed very
much like a library so you can use
individual pieces to solve specific
problems and so includes things like a
JDBC driver a sequel parser relational
algebra sort of a way to express
relational algebra as well as a very
very powerful query optimizer with a lot
of common relational transformations it
also is nice because it understands and
you may have caught the talk yesterday
if you're on the data engineering
conference track yesterday de
engineering track yesterday Julien Hyde
is the creator of the apache calcite
project and talk probably more detail
about calcite specifically I'll talk
about it in sort of a more general
context but understands materialized
views and this concept of lattices which
is an extent and sort of a nice sort of
structured way to deal with materialized
views and is used by a huge number of
projects some of the examples of Apex
drill - link khylin Phoenix Sam's a
switch storm cascading and of course I
use it inside of dromio the third
project I'm talking about is appalled
patchy Parque this is probably most
likely to be the most well-known of
these three projects
it is pretty much I would say the dis
facto standard for on disk
representation of columnar data it was
based on if I think it's six seven eight
years ago the Dremel paper came out
really the general paper didn't talk
about a lot in terms of detail but the
one thing it did focus on was a non
dissing complex data
that was highly efficient and colander
in structure and so parquet is a
open-source implementation of that
specification and it supports this
high-level concept of different kinds of
data where compression for your
different columns and also is very well
optimized for a vectorized commodore
read-back yeah it's a de facto standard
for on disk so talking about hashing
techniques I want to sort of start by
talking about what does caching mean and
what does it mean to me really so I
think that people generally think of it
as kind of one thing but I think it
needs a lot more than that and really at
the core what a caching is about is
about reducing the distance to data
right it's like how quickly can I get
the data that I need to and really
that's all about how much time does it
take and how many resources does it take
to get it to a particular amount of data
or a type of data and so that I actually
break this into three sub categories
okay the first is what I saw over on the
right here you can see sort of
performance and proximity and so that's
like how fast is the medium right how
far how near is it how near is this data
to me so is it on the same node that I'm
on is it on in-memory as opposed to on
disk is it on the CPU cache instead of
in-memory right so that is one type of
way you think about caching but there
are two others that I think are also
important the second one is this concept
of is data designed for efficient
consumption right and maybe that it
takes it's very expensive to process the
data or the data is in a way where I
have to skim them over a lot of data to
get to the specific data that I'm
interested in and so the consume ability
of the data is as important as the
performance and proximity of the data
and then the last thing is is that and
this is the one that's probably the the
biggest leap for people is is that you
also have to think about how similar is
the data to what I need to answer right
and I call this relevance right if I
need to answer how many people bought a
book yesterday in New York City if the
data is all sales for the world well
then that's quite a ways from what I
want to answer right but if the data is
all the sales in New York well that's
quite that's a little bit closer
and so how relevant is the data to what
my question is okay and so when I talk
about caching I mean it's all on all
three of these different dimensions is I
want to increase the performance and
proximity of data I want to
deal with consume ability of the data to
make the data consumable as possible but
I also want to make sure it's as
relevant as possible okay and so when we
talk about different types of caching I
actually break it into six different
kinds of caching okay and the one that
most people think about when they first
think about caching is probably the
first one but I'm going to go through
each of these and sort of talk about the
strengths and weaknesses of each and as
you might guess in order to solve most
real-world problems it's not like you're
gonna use one of these you're probably
gonna use more than one and in our case
we use five of the six so the first one
most people will know about in memory
file pinning HDFS has this capability it
was originally sort of people started to
do a lot and so the big data ecosystem
was tacking on which ultimately became
Alexio it's great for a lot of a lot of
reasons the first is is that it's very
easy to understand I understand that I
can take a file and instead of having it
on disk I have it in memory that's a
very simple concept it's a really
well-defined interface like I know how
to interact with the file system I open
a file I read it I close it I seek
that's about it
and in a perform improves the
performance of the medium right and so
hey if I can only pull it from disk at
150 Meg's a second if we're using a
spinning disk now I'm pulling from
memory I can pull opposite you know 10
gigs a second ok that's great that's
gonna way improve the things and so if
you're very your performance is bound by
your i/o throughput then in memory file
opening can be very very efficient and
very helpful that being said there's
some downsides to it too well the first
is is that the file the way that you
structure a file for a spinning disk for
example is not necessarily the way you
would want to structure it for in memory
and the trade-offs that you make are
also very different and so for example
people will frequently use some kind of
sort of high speed compression algorithm
to compress data when they drop it on to
disk because they do math like hey it's
gonna take you know I can do 500 600
Meg's a second single thread of
decompression a disk can only pull 100 a
hundred fifty Meg's and so I'm actually
not bottlenecked at all by that
compression well all of a sudden I
dropped that data into memory and all of
a sudden the compression actually slows
me way down and so I don't get the
theoretical performance of the memory
because I've got to go through this this
bottleneck and so you you're moving the
bottleneck as you do with any kind of
performance analysis the other one is is
that if you think about
data processing engines and algorithms
typically they need a they need to use
an in-memory representation of data
however it's not the disk format and so
even if you load your data into memory
as a pinna file right and then you try
to do analysis against it whatever a
tool you're using will then take the
data and make a copy of it in a
different representation most likely
in-memory to do its actual work and so
you don't actually share a lot of
benefit across different applications
you share throughput benefits but you
don't share memory management benefits
and so everybody still has to make a
copy of that data into their own
representation and so good for some
things not as good for other things but
the one that most people think about
when they think about caching the next
one I'm going to talk about is call more
disk caching and so this is about the
idea that hey you know what yes one way
to improve performance is by moving the
medium that you're interacting with but
another one is about consume ability and
if I can figure out ways to improve the
medium and consume ability that's very
very powerful and so most people might
land their data in some kind of row-wise
format like JSON or CSV or something
more custom Avro maybe on disk from a
streaming process or a logging process
or something like that that
representation is not the most efficient
for on for repeated read/write and so in
the case of repeated read I want to take
advantage of something like columnar
formats where instead of slicing things
by record by record I sliced them column
by column and one of the key reasons
that that's very beneficial is is that
most analytical applications only
interact with a few fields in a
particular data set so I might have a
data set which has hundreds or thousands
of columns but I may only want to
interact with ten of those things and so
if that's a row wise representation I
have to skip over the rest of the
columns every time I want to look at a
record but if it's called a
representation then I can just read the
few columns that I'm interested in so
that's really good for that they can
also be compressed very well because you
have data where compression and so you
can actually reduce IO from both only
reading some of the data as well as
having a very compact data right it also
is designed very well for reading back
into a common representation in memory
and vectorizing that processing now on
this flip side like anything okay if I'm
gonna make a copy of the data that's
gonna be more expensive than having the
original now some people have the
ability to land the data directly into a
Commodore format on disk but it's
generally very difficult and the reason
is at its core is is that Commodore
formats require substantially more
buffering than row-wise formats and so a
typical say a parquet file you might
actually want a buffer somewhere between
256 Meg's and 512 Meg's of data before
you spill to disk because you're
reorganizing the data at a Calm their
level and so if you've got lots of
streams coming down then you have to
worry about durability if I'm in a
buffer tottering 12 mix of stuff do I
still have to implement any log to have
my transactions before right before I
can convert it into this format and so
it's one of the things where what I see
most of the time I think most people
usually do is they land the data in a
row wise format and then later use some
kind of ETL tool to convert it into a
common format whether that spark or a
MapReduce in the olden days or whatever
or the near old in the days I guess I'd
say so
layer on top of this in memory block
caching okay in memory block caching is
the idea of hey rather than pinning the
whole file in memory I'm going to pin
individual blocks in memory and the most
common way that people are probably very
aware of this is is the Linux page cache
where basically it's gonna say hey this
is a hot block that's a hot block I'm
gonna keep those things in memory rather
than having to go back to the disk and
so very helpful if you're doing if you
have a data format which is designed for
random access and you can get the data
that you're interested in in a small
amount of random access chunks okay
another example of this is the HBase
block cache which is slightly more
custom than say a generic Linux page
cache but it's the same basic concept of
in HBase it's like hey I've got a KB
store and there's a certain set of keys
that are pretty hot and so I'm gonna
keep those in memory so in generally
very mature especially if using lyft
page cache you can get it for free but
you don't have a lot of controller
influence over it right and it's also
very disconnected from the workloads
right it's a random byte range and so if
those bytes are hot then great if those
bytes are not hot then it's awkward and
so it's actually kind of while it's it
can be beneficial and it's it's free in
a lot of cases if you look at most
analytical workloads which is kind of
what I'm focused on you're generally
doing large bulk reads and so you can
actually have problems by
blowing out the page cash and then that
kind of thing so the next type of
caching is going more on the consume
ability side of things okay and it's
what I'm calling near CPU data caching I
don't think this is a good name but I
don't have a better one someone comes up
the one I appreciate a tweet when
happening and it's basically holding the
data in a representation that can be
processed with that restructuring okay
and this is really the core of what I
was talking about before with era
it's that hey I'm gonna hold the
represent I'm gonna hold the data in the
representation that is ready to be
consumed by an application rather than
storing it in a disk format which then
has to be interpreted deserialized or
whatever before it can be processed if I
hold in a format that's very efficient
for processing then I can potentially
have multiple people interact with that
data without having to make copies of
that data in memory and it also is very
very efficient for doing different work
so if I hold data in memory that's a
near CPU data representation then what I
want to work on it I just start working
on it there's no extra work to be done
and so that's that you could ten gigs at
it I had a memory or whatever and then
you're immediately working on that as
quickly as you can work on it with the
CPU and that's cool because then you can
have multiple consumers potentially
interact with that data now there's some
flip sides to this though there's some
some challenges with as well right I
call technical decisions there's plus
some lasas everything and the first is
is that this is far larger than
compressed formats okay and so a park a
file when turned into an in-memory error
representation may be anywhere from
three to ten times larger it could be
even more than that depending on how
sparse the data is how many knows and
one of the reasons is is that an
in-memory representation something like
arrow is designed to a support random
access and so you can you don't have to
go through the first hundred records to
see the hundred and first record whereas
something like Parque is designed for
linear access and so you actually in
order to get the hundred and first
record you have to skip you have to
interact read all the first hundred
records because you don't know exactly
where the hundred and first record is
and so the other challenge with this is
is that it's sort of very sort of
central to an application in terms of
how it works with data and so
applications have to be updated to work
with this kind of representation so it's
very powerful it can provide a lot of
performance but there's also trade-offs
in terms of size and and the level of
customization you have to do to work
that the last two I'm going to talk
about in terms of caching techniques our
cube based relational caching and then
our arbitrary relational caching okay
and again names that I given these
things they're not you're not gonna be
able to go out there and find the
Wikipedia article on these things but
huge cube base relational caching is
something we've known about for a long
times think you think basically molap
right and so the idea is basically is
you pre aggregate certain sub certain
pieces of a partial aggregations of data
put them in cuboids and then when a user
comes in and wants a particular data set
you can pick what is the right one to
use okay very great provides very low
latency for common aggregation patterns
and in many cases cube storage
requirements for common patterns can be
vastly smaller than the original data
set so yes it takes a little bit of
resources but not a lot now the flip
side is is that for cube based
relational caching is is that the
analysis that the interaction of data
the interaction speed with data the
ability to retrieve data quickly it's
very bimodal okay if I get a cube hit I
get answers basically instantaneously or
close to it okay but if I miss the cube
then I've got to go back to the raw data
and who knows how long that gonna take
to get back right the other one is is
that cubes are kind of it's kind of
difficult to use a cube to satisfy an
arbitrary query pattern it's great if
I'm like okay I'm doing a tableau
workflow where I'm grouping by a
grouping by be summing see right if I
start wanting to drop into their window
functions or arbitrary expression trees
and those kinds of things there's ways
to solve some of these things but in
general it breaks down when you have
sort of an arbitrary query pattern that
you need for a dashboard or something
like that and so that is why you bring
in the second concept which is arbitrary
relational caching and so this is
similar idea to cubing which is
basically is I'm going to create an
alternative version of data and I'm
going to use that in replacement of
going to the original source and
reconstructing the answer but I'm gonna
use it for arbitrary an arbitrary design
right so okay I want to do a window
frame join these two tables and then you
know doing their section with this other
thing and that is an arbitrary query
pattern I want to
that faster because I know that some
frequently I'm gonna interact with some
subset of that data right and so
arbitrary relational caching you start
to see these triangles that's what I use
to describe these graphs of different
operations and so you might say hey I'm
gonna have this green triangle which is
a set of operations I want to solve but
I can solve some portion of it with the
purple and the blue triangles okay
so it's great because it's very simple
it's like oh this sub portion of what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna save that aside
and then reuse that rather than having
to go do that for every single time and
that also means that you can improve the
performance of basically any kind of
workload the flip side is is that it's
one complex to match arbitrary queries
queries are very very complicated and
there's lots of different ways that they
can sort of be patterned and so being
able to recognize that this is roughly
the same as our this this can be
replaced with this is actually a fairly
complicated problem and the other thing
is is that arbitrary caching can be
large right an arbitrary cache could be
a copy of the whole data set and if I
have a copy the whole data set well of
course I'm gonna be paying twice the
storage cost right but it does allow you
to sort of fit your caching to a
particular business use case no matter
what the pattern is there and so I've
got a little feedback on this will see
if you guys think it makes sense give me
a red card if it doesn't make sense but
this is kind of how I think about how
these things all fit together and so
you've got sort of the two accesses sort
of performance and proximity on as on
the y-axis and then you've got the
distance between representation in
question on the x-axis okay and so in
the x-axis world you have sort of the
consume ability dimension I was talking
about before and then the relevance
dimension right and so the perfect
situation the best possible version of a
cache is something that is highly
performance very proximate to your to
yours to your CPU is very very
consumable and is highly relevant to
your question right now of course that
is a very custom spot a place in the in
the graph we know that the the cost of
mediums go up as they become more
performant and so you're gonna be very
expensive to put stuff there and we also
know that the more you move across on
the right on on the x axis the more
specific your answer is right so if I
have a raw data set which has every fact
in the world
then that data second sentence answer
every question but it's a long ways from
answering a particular question if I
have an answer to one question that I
know I'm gonna be able to answer that
question very very quickly but it's only
gonna satisfy a small amount of things
and so it's very hard right to get to
that top right because you have to worry
about both the applicability of what
you're doing and the scarcity of the
resources is required to be able to get
at it and so this is kind of how I lay
these things out so in memory file
opinion in memory block caching very
good at being performant and proximate
right but really have no influence on
the conservative things or the relevance
of things right so you can go out into
the right with near CPU data caching
right which gives you improved consume
ability and also performance in
proximity by sitting that in memory but
you're also know you're gonna use way
more more and more space than you might
use if you're doing something like in
file template pinning call more disk
caching on their hand generally speaking
it's a disk cache okay so it's gonna be
as fast as in memory but it's going to
substantially improve consume ability
and also not use that many resources now
what gets really exciting is when you
look at the two kinds of relational
caching right and so relational caching
starts to move you out on this relevance
curve which really allows you to make
magnitudes of difference in terms of
performance whereas many of these other
techniques you get you know 2 X 5 X
depending on what your particular use
case is maybe you can find a use case
that's you know really awesome but
you're not usually going to get
magnitudes which of these things you're
just gonna sort of be hey I can scale
out of my system or whatever to improve
latency but when you use cube relational
caching an arbitrary relational caching
you have an ability to really do a good
job of solving the relevance problem and
therefore substantially reducing that
distance to data and so when we built
what we built a dreamy o we focused on
all these different things and started
to evaluate what are the things that we
think make the biggest impact to
people's workloads and we actually
decided to take some combination of five
of the six of these we actually don't do
in memory file pinning but we actually
put together together five to try to
solve the problems that people have and
so let's talk about those two last
categories use relational caching and
how that works specifically okay and I'm
going to start out with a very this is
not a lot of content on this but a very
quick
relational algebra refresher ok
relational algebra is a way to Express
you work with data that's a very generic
I know but it has sort of these sort of
key concepts relations so a source of
data so I'm like get it data from a
particular table whether that's on it
because it's a CSV file on disk or a
relational database table or you know a
collection MongoDB whatever the case may
be and then you have operators and
operators are basically transformations
how do I go from one state of data to
another state of data and then you have
properties or what can where sometimes
called traits and a property of data is
some nature to the stream of data as
it's moving out out of that operation
right and so if I sort some data then
afterwards it has a trait or a property
which is sordidness you may have a
property of distribution of the data
inside of a distributed cluster okay you
then have rules rules define basically
how you can manipulate a set of
operators from one representation to
another representation and those things
are equivalent okay and so the whole
concept of working with relational
algebra is is that I can take a tree
that looks like one thing and do a bunch
of changes to it and I know it has the
same meaning I'm gonna get the same data
out of the first tree and the second
tree but the second tree is somehow
substantially better for performance in
terms of how I'm doing the work right
and then lastly you basically I talked
about graphs or trees which is a
collection of these operators that are
collected together with relations at the
leaf nodes and basically moving this
data into a representation that's
relevant to me and so when we talk about
relational algebra right one of the
common things that we want to do is we
want to do some kind of transformation
and say that these two things are equal
and a very simple version of this might
be what's on the right hand side of this
slide which is is that originally I have
something which is a scanning of data
followed by a projection I only want
three of the columns of data followed by
a filter right and maybe I want that
maybe it's sorry for projection maybe I
want three of the columns I want ABC and
then I also want to add D and E together
and make F right and then afterwards I
want to filter by a that is greater than
ten all right so that might be a very
simple relational algebra expression
that's saying hey this is how I want to
get to a particular data set right you
can have a rule which says hey you know
what actually it makes sense before I do
the division the addition of D plus E
making F I could actually filter the
data on a and that means I can do less
work of the D plus E equals F right I
have to do less of those because I
filtered out some portion of the data
right and so that's a
very simple relational algebra
transformation I'm going to change the
project and filter so that the filter
comes before the projection right and
that's going to improve my performance
so that's relational algebra refresher
very quick relational caching is
basically saying okay now that I see
that there's some commonality two
different things I want to hold some
intermediate state so you have some
original data and you have different
things that you want I have what you
want a what you want B and what you want
C right and so normally if I wanted to
answer each of those things I would say
hey I'm gonna go and have to go from the
original data and I'm have to derive
what what I want right and that's you
know you know a certain amount of
distance to data okay but if I realize
that those three what you wants have
some intermediate shared state which is
closer to the answer but is not the
answer if I can persist that state and
use that instead that all of a sudden
I've substantially recent reduced the
distance the data for the individual
questions right and so that can reduce
to reduce my latency it can also reduce
my resource requirements and so that is
the basic concept of relational caching
just saying hey I'm gonna get something
this closer but not the answer and use
that for multiple different situations
now as you may be thinking already I
already do this most people do this
already and what that means is is that
you know what I may have some raw data
that was in JSON I convert it into Park
a file I've got a dashboard that I need
to have supported and so I'm gonna then
to convert that into a summarized
version of the data set alright and so I
might session eyes the data cleanse it I
might partition it by time or region I
may summarize it for a particular
purpose like a dashboard and then I have
the users or the developers pick which
one to use
right so they may say oh okay I know
that I'm doing a you know longitudinal
analysis so I'm gonna use data set X
version of the version X of the data set
and oh now I'm doing a tableau dashboard
so I'm gonna use a version Y the same
data set and so this works right and as
long as you don't have too many choices
it can work pretty well what happens
though is is that as you add more and
more choices you get into an awkward
situation right and this is where
relational caching really comes into
play is is that normally a user comes
into your analysts or your end-users new
developers the data developers come in
and start trying to figure out which
data sets to work with you based
we have to train them on what's the
right one to use and that can be very
challenging for users to learn Oh
implicitly oh this is the right one or
that's the right one all the time
especially because if they're working
through some crime analysis problem they
may start with one data set and as
they're working and building up queries
and type of queries and type of queries
it may make sense for them to actually
switch to another data set in the middle
of that work but they've already built
up this whole stack of sequel queries to
get to what they want to and the odds
that they're gonna take the inner part
of that query and change it out with
something else is very very low and so
people all the time use what I would
call a copy and pick strategy which is
I'm going to copy the data and or drive
a piece of data and then I'm gonna have
the users pick the right one based on
their use case okay which does solve a
bunch of these problems but it it
becomes big a bigger problem when you
have hundreds or thousands of these
choices that an analyst has to make and
the analyst is not necessarily incentive
to even make the right choice they don't
necessarily want to spend the time to
think about this and so relational
caching is this concept of saying hey
you know what let's make the cache pick
the right version of the data the user
can always interact with the raw data or
some virtual version of the data but the
end-user but the system can then make
the choice of which which physical
representation of the data is most
satisfactory for saddling that as
quickly as possible so it's moving the
the responsibility of the pic and copy
to the individual in the cache and the
second part is is also moving the
maintenance of those copies to the cache
from having some you know data engineer
or data admin who is responsible for
maintaining all these representations
okay so it's something you already do
today it's just saying hey let's make
the system do this rather than making
end-users do it because then users are
gonna make mistake or not necess I have
the time to think about these things and
so building a relational caches we did
we started with okay what are the key
components and the first is is basically
how do you express transformations in
States and there's multiple ways you can
do it you could do it code based we've
thought that sequel made the most sense
it fits to at least a lot of the
people's understanding of how to express
different types of transformations and
so let's use sequel and so then okay
once we do that how do you hold and
manage these relational algebra
representations and there that's when we
took calcite we said we're gonna use
calcite to solve this because it's a
very good toolkit for that then you say
okay well I'm gonna cache these
different versions the data I want to
persist that how do I persist that well
that's when we use park' so we said ok
let's use parquet dough's
Syst it and then there's a need after
that you persist these datasets to
separate what the cached version of the
data is to the actual answer so if you
go back to this picture here listen
there you go back to this picture here
right we still have the second part at
the top so you see that yeah so we still
have this part at the top that we have
to do we've cut out the bottom part here
we don't have to do that anymore but we
still have to do this top part and so we
need something to do that top part and
so then we say okay well the way we can
do that is we can use arrows and in
memory resin tation processing and then
we built an open-source engine on top of
that called subo which is designed to
process that quickly and bridge the gap
between what the data representation is
and what the actual question is that the
person is trying to answer and so that
off yeah so there's all a lot of other
code that got to put in there and go
look at it or get up but this is kind of
how it came out okay is basically is is
that you're gonna have a UI to define
your different cached patterns and
that's going to interact with two
different things a change detection
database and a relational pattern
database
okay so relational patterns are very
useful because then you might have an
end user query comes in you go in and
you're gonna use the query planner in
this case calcite and we have a
relational pattern matching system
that's built inside of calcite that is
responsible for figuring out what are
the right relational patterns that can
help to solve this particular question
that is then handed into a data
processing system which is the sabo and
that is interacting with arrow
representations to work with data down
below you have different kinds of data
that you're interacting with with us
data in HDFS s3 elastic relational
whatever and then you have a storage a
source storage interface which is going
to be producing arrow data and bringing
that into the processing system but then
you also have this other thing which is
the refreshed system and the refreshed
system misted matt is responsible for
reading data out of these individual
systems based on change detection
different kinds of change detection and
moving that into the persistence layer
which is a park a representation of data
and so when a particular user quest
question comes in we may actually
interact with the cache data entirely
and we realize that we can satisfy the
entire answer by taking cache did it and
then further transforming it or it may
be that it satisfies that you can't
satisfy it with cash bidding you have to
go back to the source or more likely you
actually have some combination of the
two it may be that I have some portion
of the data cache made my a fact
it's been a great admirer size and I can
use that but I will still go to a
dimension table inside of my relational
database rather than caching that data
and so basically being able to combine
cache in some situations and not cache
in other situations so all right I'm
gonna go through I only got another 15
slides so we'll go quick so definition
matching so okay this is what relational
caching is trying to do how do you do it
this is coming back to calcite calcite
is this great toolkit which has all
these different ways of expressing how
these things work together and it has
comes with all these pre-built tools
like here's all the operators that I
might want to have here's a bunch of
rules here's a bunch of properties
here's I can transform between two
things and it also has a really cool
materialized view facility okay and so
for those of you who come from
relational database background
well relational caching is basically
materialized views revisited so that
they're outside the database all right
now they're also enhanced in various
other ways but that's the way you can
think about it and so hey look at
calcite becomes a great foundational
component for building a relational
caching system and so how we think about
it is we had to come up with entities
you have to come up with ways of
thinking about the individual objects
that's useful and so we came up with
this concept of reflection the
reflection is basically a persisted
version of the data that may satisfy
some alternative portion of that date of
the original dataset okay we persist
those in a parquet format and then we
have two main sub concepts of
reflections we have what called raw
reflections which is basically a
persistent version of the data set that
includes maybe some of the columns or
all of the columns but it's partitioned
and sorted in a particular way right so
my dataset might be initially in a JSON
representation I may say I'm gonna
create a raw reflection of that data set
where I only include half of the fields
and I'm gonna partition it by date and
I'm going to sort it by transaction
amount right so that's raw reflections
aggregate reflections is the second
concept which is sort of to support more
of the cube view of the world which is
to define dimensions and measures on a
data set and say I want to create
various levels of roll-ups or partial
aggregations against those dimensions
and measures and as you can still in
that case control both partitioning and
sordidness and so these two tools are
actually very powerful because they can
always be layered on top of virtual
datasets so yes I can create a raw
reflection against a data set which is
just the
source data set but I can also create a
reflection against some arbitrary set of
transformations I've created and so I
want to do a window frame I'm going to
do an intersection and then I want that
to be a virtual data set and then I can
apply a raw reflection on top of that
and make that be the persistent data set
and I can still make those choices
around partitioning and sordidness only
including some of the columns so that I
can decide how you can think about these
the robbery flexion kind of like a
covering index of either of a virtual or
our physical data set
aggghhhhh reflection is more like cubes
and so these are all built to allow us
to do what is basically decisions around
using alternative versions of the data
and so as an example here we may have a
query which is a I'm using abbreviations
over here to make this sort of compact
but basically we're scanning some data
we're doing a projection of only a
couple of columns of the data we're then
doing an aggregation and then we are
going to be filtering some data okay
this is what the user comes in he says
I'm gonna interact with raw data I'm
gonna do these operations
well we define a reflection in the
middle of this world right which says
hey I'm gonna say that X is equal to Y
here and that's target is equal to
materialisation so if a user has this
part of the query
in their query it may not be the queries
exactly that but they're part of the
query can be get turned in to this then
I can instead of using that target I can
actually use a materialization that I
created which is that work already done
right and so what happens here is is
that I may have originally wanted to
have to do an aggregation against the
large fact table but it turns out I have
another aggregation which is covering
the aggregation that I'm asking for and
so instead of using the raw aggregation
against the raw table I'm gonna
aggravate against this materialization
this reflection instead and therefore
I'm gonna do another plan now the plan
doesn't look less expensive when you
look at it just as blocks because it's
three blocks versus floor compares but
the reality is in this case is that the
scan in this case can be you know
several magnitudes less amount of
records and so the over amount of work
here is far less and so this is an
aggregation roll-up matching case and so
you were to say hey I see this pattern
in the query I'm gonna replace it with
something else so there are other things
like this and there are lots and lots of
these different kinds of patterns
another example is a joint aggregation
matching pattern and so you transpose
the two and so it may be that my raw
query here are my original query is an
aggregation on top of a join of two
tables right well it may be that I have
a materialization which is an
aggregation on top of one of those
two tables not an aggregation on top of
both of those two tables well there's a
bunch of rules that you can use to swap
these things around and actually come up
with a tree that uses that that I pre
aggregated data set on one side and do
some other work on the other side to
come up with the right answer and all of
a sudden again you've substantially
reduced the amount of work and so there
are lots of these different
transformations one more example is is
that there's actually not one
transformation you can actually come up
with minion you may come up with
multiple replacement simultaneously and
so it's not only about coming up with
what matches it's coming up with the
best match and so here's an example
where I might have two raw materials
Asians or two more on reflections one
which is based on which is sort of
partitioned by a and wonder if it is
partitioned by B a user comes in and
wants to do a scan of data and then
filter by a okay well as you might guess
it's much better to use the
materialization where I'm partitioned by
a because then I can just quickly prune
all the partitions and never actually
have to apply the filter at runtime as
opposed to use the data set which is
partitioned by B and so all of a sudden
I get a new plan which is the scan of
just the raw data that's partitioned by
B part by a but only the valid A's that
are relevant to the query so lots and
lots of different patterns like this and
you can we can talk more about those
Softline come and chat with me about it
but there's lots of different ways of
approaching these different matching
problems to solve hey how can I solve
this question with this other answer so
lastly just quick couple slides on
dealing with updates so as a cache you
have to think about updates too and
maybe in a perfect world there would be
no change to your data it's a data set
from the census data from from 2010 so I
don't have to worry about any changes
that would be great but most of us don't
work with that kind of data the earth
data is changing all the time and so
when we thought about that we solved it
in kind of two different ways the first
is we thought about refresh management
and so two sub components of this is
fresh miss management right when you're
interacting with the data as an end user
you want to be able to know that the
data is no longer than is no older than
something right so you need to have a
guarantee that the data's no older than
something but you also want to probably
achieve something that's more fresh than
that right worst-case scenario it's no
older than three hours but I'd like it
to be updated every 10 minutes and so
that's how we broke it down is you can
set a refresh time which is how often
you want the data updated but if you did
the system is really loaded or the data
hasn't showed up yet then you can set a
tolerance for how old the data can be
before we actually
start serving directly from the source
rather than from the cache and so you
can say okay I want to set an absolute
TTL expiration date to the data as well
and decide between those two things the
other thing to think about is is that
when you are updating these different
representations there is a good way and
a bad way to update there was lots of
ways to update them but most of them are
not as good as the best way and the idea
is is that you probably are going to
create multiple relational caches of the
same data at once and what you want to
do is you want to calculate what's the
optimal order of updating all of these
things so that I can do the minimum
amount of work because if I have for
example a rah reflection and then I have
an aggregate reflection there are
reflection which will be columnar and in
the aggregate which is gonna also be
calmer it's a lot better to do the
robbery flection first because now I
have an optimal representation that I
can do the aggregate reflection on top
of rather than say going back to the
json source twice okay and so the other
thing that we focused on was building
basically a dependency graph of the
different relations to figure out what's
the optimal way that we can reflect we
refreshed all these things to minimize
the amount of overtime time and this is
one of the big benefits of having a
system do this rather than the end user
so any users try to do this but they
can't do it nearly as well as not end
users data admins of data engineers try
to do this because they say oh I know
this is better to come before that does
but it's still very difficult to figure
out all those relationships and do that
well and so instead having a system do
this actually makes things a lot easier
and then lastly you think about updates
themselves mutations how do you deal
with the mutations and we basically came
up with sort of four main ways that we
deal with mutations the first is what we
call the full update which is the most
obvious it's like I'm just gonna copy
all the data again I'm not gonna worry
about the mutations and the reason that
this is important is is that some data
is mutating so fast they're trying to
track the individual chat and changes
it's not gonna make sense to try to
track those back ok but in some in many
other cases mutation patterns can be
more predictable and so the two that are
really the most common for large
datasets are basically append appending
patterns and that might be for files so
hey as new files a new directory show up
I'm gonna take advantage of that or as
if you've got a roast or like a you know
relational database or something like
that I may have a column which is a
constantly increasing column and so I'm
going to use that column to identify new
records that have been inserted so those
are two ways to sort of deal with
append-only situations and so then you
can say hey I want to get snapshot of
everything that's changed
the last time I interacted with the data
and just make incremental updates to
individual reflections based on that and
then the last is actually a partition
refresh which we found actually the most
useful and partition refresh is the
concept that I'm gonna break my data
into individual partitions and sometimes
some of the partitions are going to
mutate but it's very rare that all the
partitions mutate and so typically only
the most recent partition is mutating if
you use partitions of time which is what
most people do and so this allows you to
constantly update some one portion of
the data but maintain the rest of the
data and so you can sort of have a a
moving data set of the last 30 days and
you can refresh it every 10 minutes but
every refresh is only an interact with a
partition from today so closing words
using these techniques we've seen I hate
I'm not using benchmarks here but we
have seen huge amounts of impact by
using this technique as you might guess
right if you get the clip data as close
as possible to the question then you're
gonna be able to improve the performance
substantially and at the same time you
can vastly reduce the amount of
resources and in many cases this is the
interesting part that's not necessarily
intuitive is is that we in many cases
actually reduce the total amount of disk
consumptions required for use cases and
the reason is is because people are
already doing these techniques but they
can't be as good at it as a computer and
so while we may actually create more
reflections we can realize that certain
reflections are more sort of relying on
each other and avoid having to create
duplicates of things that are basically
the same whereas an enormous
organization to different users may have
a different use case which is
substantially overlapping and you're
gonna make two different copies of the
data for that purpose so find out more
get involved whatever you like to do I'm
doing office hours in the East Room
right after this or the East Room lounge
I said east room east ramp lounge not
East Room sorry there's a dreamy Oh
table behind me behind you not behind me
where one of my co-workers is giving
some overviews of what we do at Dromio
and the product there so you can sort of
see what that looks like we're actually
doing an Apache era made up tomorrow in
Midtown at enigma Tech thank you enigma
Tech so if you want to come and join us
we'll have West McKinney who's the
creator of pendous they're talking about
arrow as well as I'm doing a talk that's
sort of a deep technical talk on arrow
joining communities so Jeremy oh there's
Jeremy Oh community we've got a github
site we can go download our product and
try it out come and talk to us about
what's going on with that we also I'm
very engaged in a bunch of these
open-source projects
Eero calcite parquet so go and join
those development channels go enjoying
those mailing lists and check those
things out and that's all I got thank
you so much for your time guys
[Applause]
[Music]